hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
candy's - we're starting the fifth night
and as you saw in the last episode it
got a little insane there but I have
calmed down I've done a lot of
meditation I need to start working right
now bo hey how's it going there I've
done a lot to try to get through this
and I'm gonna be a-okay so no need to
worry about me let's just try to get
through the night in one piece now the
other thing that I was told is that
there is an easter egg here with that
character the character on the wall back
there the smiling female cat type thing
oh damn it I wasn't ready for that
oh no I tried to put it down but it
didn't work okay Lisa back up that was
quick
okay so we're fine here okay I got to
readjust it because every time I come
into this I keep thinking that the
control scheme is gonna be more like you
know five nights at freddys instead of
five nights at candy's
and I have a feeling hey okay good damn
it I alright anyway that worked out for
me so I still don't fully understand the
mechanics of blank he's he's a bit of an
enigma at this point but that's okay
it's gonna be over there no you do not
know you do not oh whoa I got to be
quicker on that one because it's Pangu
that really gets me ah damn it man I
need those I need those for stuff and
things alright who's coming you're
coming okay always clear thus far and I
should be getting this camera back or
this phone back pretty soon
maybe I can lead blank into this room
again it works
okay so blank goes back to that room but
I don't know if he goes into any other
room no you do not come on let's not be
ridiculous here okay who blank is really
crawling all over me okay so there there
also I've been told I've been told I'm
not a hundred percent sure on this one
but I've been told that there's actually
an animatronic of me in the game and I
don't know how accurate that is but
that's just what I've been told so
hopefully we'll come across beautiful me
at some point in the near future he is
really close to coming my way
oh boy can fully flesh out a sentence
why is no one going for that hello
Oh God please go away nan you not what I
wanted
why are you hanging out there stop that
oh god that's not what I wanted to sell
what do i please don't be behind this
screen okay okay okay so I'm pretty sure
he only goes to one camera 11 which is
interesting because that's the only one
that I've been able to draw him to oh
god don't do that mangu you've been kind
of nice to me so far
I appreciate it at this point I'd rather
be alone so I got to make sure that the
other animatronics aren't in this area
here which causes a lot of problems
where the hell is everybody oh I don't
like this
Oh God okay hello blankie okay so you're
over there now I need to hear things a
little bit better I always turn down the
volume because I don't want to get
jumpscared too badly okay we're fine
fine who's there
okay just you that's fine no one's here
we're doing great it's 3:00 a.m. and we
only got a few hours left until our
untimely demise
and there was blanket so that means that
we have a window of opportunity here
also at popular request I turned off the
light behind me so that it's a little
darker more atmospheric here what is
Lego barking at its an animatronic
bashing down my door are you trying to
get me now
am i coming to kill me cuz I turned off
the lights okay well not all the lights
obviously I have this one light on my
face okay I have a feeling the blank is
gonna be wandering down the hallway and
even to know with his [ __ ] ugly face and
his stupid grin and his ugly smile and
his bad teeth and horrible breath
thought I heard knocking maybe I can't
tell it's in real life and what's not in
real life anymore
uh-huh it's blurring the lines between
reality junkie right no I got a pull
blank back in here because I don't even
know where flank is Oh legs right there
okay please thank you oh my god okay so
that's true blank does only go there and
then he makes a full loop around the
entire building and then I can pull him
back into that one because he's adjacent
to that one
so that does help it helps it okay where
are you no no no no no Giordano no Jojo
no no okay blanks over there why is he
over there he did not make a full loop
unless I just wasn't watching him okay
yeah but he's over there now and that's
good that's good
go away please Oh God Oh I'm just
staring at him oh what a lovely person
you are I'm just gonna oh no no no no
okay fine
stop banging on the walls not what I
want
Oh God blank blank like moo moo
moo-moo-moo-moo yes yes I got you on
lockdown you're so stupid then you just
follow the sound of the same phone
ringing over and over again
it's so stupid what a dum-dum an
itty-bitty dum-dum hello again you're
back already you really want to kill me
towards the end of this night don't you
holy crap you are adamant about killing
me dead gather you're none of that none
of that none of that none of that no no
I just like to keep people in room one
because it does serve as double function
to keep him here and so long as I don't
let him rip the phone out of the wall
everything is gonna be fine
this place was nice before you started
ripping things out of the wall you [ __ ]
ugly bastard but a Helen be ugly they're
ugly it up with your terrible face right
stop
at star oh oh oh damn it why why would
you make that a jump-scare I don't
appreciate it it's not something that's
good for me oh okay we made it through
that we're doing okay so long as we find
out what the hell this is all about what
am i searching for and why am i doing it
I got my tie back because candy did that
or Cindy did that for me and that was
awfully nice of her but then I have a
funny feeling that she was disassembled
in a horrible way by Radhika's who's
still hiding in the closet coming out of
the closet Radhika's why'd you go and
then why can't I go that way
wasn't that a path that I could go
before probably why isn't that a path
that I can go before this does the music
different than what it was because it's
getting awfully honky and I think if I'm
not mistaken this is the layout of five
nights at candy's one hello who the hell
are you who the hell do you think you
are security guard oh hi are the police
here oh I took me a second to register
that those are flashing police lights
red and blue all this tall man I had
chills running down my spine oh no I
have a funny feeling that Radhika's is
at the heart of oh oh that's not good
[ __ ] you
hi [ __ ] you I didn't do anything what
the hell that guy was really happy to be
tasing me an animatronic like I had a
big old smile on his face old factory
set for demolition the abandoned Factory
on st. Antonious Road 27 has been
scheduled for demolition sometime next
week the now 45 year old factory closed
in 1993 after it was deemed unsafe due
to yet another fatal incident inside the
factory yeah yet another death the
factory used to belong to robotics Corp
a company that went bankrupt shortly
after the factory closed the company was
specialized in the design of production
of robotic animatronics they started in
1962 where they made mechanical wire
controlled animatronics and over the
years their animatronics got more
advanced a total of six casualties
occurred in the factory over the past 45
years the most remarkable one being in
1987 when a pair of twins went missing
and were later discovered to have been
killed in one of the assembly machines
in the factory as selling author sell
out well that's an interesting follow up
headline okay then do I
okay here we go so I'm oh I'm assuming
if pattern fall yeah I thought for sure
it was gonna a blood-red Knight 6 just
like my hair let's find out what's going
on here I don't think I'm gonna win
right off the bat but I'm gonna do my
best like I always do I'm going to try
try very hard oh yeah whoo oh I don't
know how to deal with you oh that ain't
good what Oh
oh no what how do I do I scare you
haha what are you Oh what are you what
are you oh I had your time my sass got
blasted that guy is coming down home
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
do we do I don't know what to do okay
well I am controlled why am i back girl
murdered again Marilyn Schmidt stupid
sister Mike Schmidt found dead because
she couldn't be less stupid anyway let's
try that one more time before we wrap up
hi peg do or you knew you weren't there
before what are you doing here
well it's try night six again there was
something about it then going away from
the invert right and there was one
moment there when I pulled up the camera
it was a camera of just this main area
and that was like super disorient them
so weird okay where did you go what are
you doing there stop that
stop stop Oh God hello hi oh you're
still here
we're but don't do that no oh no oh no
no no oh what do I do
I don't know what to do hello oh you're
both here
good well why are you both here Oh God
worried hi boss doing here why why I
don't know if I'm supposed to chase you
guys one hello
oh [ __ ] god damn it with the SAP what
are you doing oh god he did it again
oh no not that one stop that your
radhika's it's Radhika's and then
catechist I think
Radhika's and catechists archiving
trying to ha oh god oh man those not the
friendliest bunches that I've ever seen
oh boy oh stop that good
oh no he's not going for it he's not
going for it he's 140 where did he go
for it
where did he come from where to go where
radhika's go where the hell what the
[ __ ] okay everything seems okay
oh hi hello will you both do you freaky
[ __ ] like I have no time I have no
time
oh god it did it again oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh boy okay okay so it's
it's it's generally the same rules as
before generally just I have no time if
I see the face I got a leg flip it down
whoa hello goodbye oh god what do I do
about you mm-hmm okay not that yet not
yet not there yet not dead yet
not that yet I can make it through this
night I can make it through these
horrible horrible creatures hello
you're gonna rip it out of the wall it's
do something about it yeah you run away
Oh nope nothing for you I'm legitimately
[ __ ] it wasn't quick I wasn't ready I
was gonna flip through another one oh
god oh god oh god it's doing things to
and saying doing saying hello goodbye
oh [ __ ] me oh god oh god he went away Oh
God
hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh god
you did it again this is looking at here
but that's not okay
it's so weird and creepy I don't like
that I don't like that
oh boy okay welcome back are you doing
I'm just gonna leave that oh okay
oh well that's handy bad huh it's gonna
leave that ringing I guess doesn't seem
to be a penalty for not letting it ring
I read a kiss oh that's not a good sound
oh boy I've done there hello again
welcome back don't you dare don't you
dare
good good you okay now that I got the
situation handled I think this is
actually gonna be okay everything's
gonna be okay Nellie stop stop just stop
stop catechist catechist your son of a
[ __ ] who 4:00 a.m. okay
don't do that don't do that so weird
now I feel very alone my goodness okay
they're both here
man that catechist guy he moves like
like over lightning a wise Marilyn
Schmitt back that's another question
that I have why does she keep coming
back
I can understand Mike Schmidt working
for minimum wage and wanting to come
back just because he has nothing else to
do with him wife [ __ ] okay okay okay we
can make it we can make it all the way
you can make it all the way
oh god please Bluth
thank you make it all the way make it
all the way don't yeah that's right hey
you better skedaddle all gods 5:00 a.m.
oh god oh god if I can just avoid death
if I can just avoid the horrible feeling
of death approaching with me from all
angles then I will be okay
it's like a haunting ring from down the
road
there's always this one you always likes
to go for that one
Oh God don't no no no no no no me yes
okay radhika's you're gonna play nice
they're gonna play nice in the last hour
of the game nothing gonna play nice
they're gonna play nice Hong for good
luck [ __ ] honk damn it Oh God which one
which one is it the same one oh it's the
same one whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa honk aah
oh man once I had that unlock down it
was pretty simple it was okay let's find
out with the final mystery here's what
do we got what the hell happened to the
last one that's a question
who is that that Momo
oh no no Momo no likey Momo no no oh no
mama was like the last one oh hi MA
huh hi was that open before I don't
think it was open before I don't know if
it was open hi hi yeah I'll follow you
Oh hurry greyguy oh god what okay he's
it's gonna taze me and I'm gonna fall
over
oh I'm still playing oh well I'm awake
now blank is moving out didn't blank
didn't blank have something else in this
game I'm pretty sure blank had another
little minigame here what are the papers
gonna reveal this time my favorite cat
okay good then okay that was a frantic
experience in that last night that was
seriously frankly I didn't need to panic
as much as I did it's just that my heart
was racing a million miles an hour
because I was facing the unknown and
surprisingly doing well which was a
shock to me so now Kreutz is more calmly
Oh dancing I thought I didn't I see
these before
oh no this is 1976 now this is a
completely different time period 1976
why are these like were these like all
the incidents that people got killed
throughout this thing baby
let me just double-check I'm pretty sure
this just loops back to where I was
before but let me just double-check yeah
it's it's it was there another one down
here there was good thing I checked and
I'm pretty sure that's the windows
friend even though that cat is flying
flying blood crying blood flying blood
it's two more catechist and Radhika's
are gonna have a good time all right
candies burgers em new candies burgers
and candies burgers in something much
like bob's burgers but not quite as
delicious thank you thank you trombone
man oh look oh hi Shadowcat you know
uh-huh how's it going there you think
you scare blank-blank is an impassive
ugly [ __ ] he has to look at him blankets
look at himself in the mirror but okay
hello kids do you need help don't mind
the giant walking animatronic full of
nightmares uh unless shadow hi shadow
cat don't mind me kitties I'll be right
back you enjoy your burgers in them
hello you want your neck snapped I could
do that for you real easy I mean it's
gotta be a little disconcerting to see
this giant walking animatronic hi oh so
happy even brought a baby here everyone
is just having a delightful time except
for me
why are they laughing at him why is he
enjoying being laughed at
are they laughing at the guy in the
security room or something oh okay I see
I see what's happening here
I see oh no okay
Oh crying child
oh no oh hi ray Oh goodbye now this is
1987 no alrighty then here we go either
Oh till I go outside I can whoops
really no I can't it doesn't want me to
go there not yet anyway I'm not free
hello wait where did all the kids go
what huh oh okay
uh-huh oh okay well then I think I
straight up murdered that guy factory
burned to the ground
the old abandoned robotics factory that
was scheduled for demolition had got
fired this morning the exact cause of
the fire is unknown but experts were
able to deduct that the fire originated
this from somewhere within the warehouse
department of the factory it was also
discovered that the factories power
schedule had not been discontinued when
the factory closed so the cause would
most likely either faulty wiring or
overloaded heating equipment the local
fire brigade arrived at the factory
around 7:00 a.m. where already most of
the building was engulfed in flames
around 8:00 a.m. the building then
finally collapsed leaving nothing but
rubble the worst something's the worst
down there I think worst movie okay
so that might be the end of the story
but there's extra materials here and we
might have oh well this happy-go-lucky
ah okay
ah so why did they make new versions of
them if they were just gonna be withered
hello blank hello chests chester your
name was chester oh there's tangu man
didn't even see Pangu in the game was he
anywhere in there I don't remember him
being there the rat I the cat rat a kiss
and catechist I was I was more correct
than I knew oh look at them look at them
looks good
yeah looks looks good here we go we're
gonna view the jump school how he's
doing
I never got gotten for you her okay
seven of 20 oh no I don't want to do 720
mode there's a normal and a question
mark I want to do those I don't think I
have the patience to do those but maybe
I'll give them a try another episode
I'll explore around I've been very lacks
about doing the 2020 modes on these
fan-made games mostly because I want to
keep my sanity intact but thank you
everybody so much for watching this is
five nights at candy's - for now I still
haven't found all the secrets if there's
another way if it's true that there's an
animatronic of me in the game let me
know but I'm not on it wasn't sure about
that that might have just been a rumor
that I read in the comments so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
all the other cool five nights at
Freddy's related stuff in the
description below and thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye samantha explodes oh
god